what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so with Star Wars the last Jedi
coming out which I'm really really
excited about I'm really really hyped
about that movie because it would be
like the first time that Disney creates
a movie that's not kind of like a remake
of another one I mean it's that's one of
the things that's really up for debate
you know with Star Wars The Force
awakens basically just like a reskin
episode for it I'm not gonna get into
that huge debate because fans argue
about that right now
it's pretty intense if you go into Star
Wars forums or the Star Wars subreddit
or something like that you'll see a lot
of people who are arguing over whether
or not the force awakens was a reskin of
episode 4 but regardless of the scenario
what I want to do here is I want to run
over the origin of the Jedi and I think
it's kind of cool now one thing I want
you guys to keep in mind is that when it
comes to Star Wars lore there is a frame
of reference and the frame of reference
is basically the final battle of Star
Wars Episode four when they blew up the
Death Star for the very first time
usually in Star Wars lore that's
referred to as the Battle of Yavin and
so what you'll have is somebody will say
36 thousand years BBY that means thirty
thousand years before the Battle of
Yavin before that actual battle in Star
Wars Episode four now the reason why
people say before the Battle of Yavin
instead of thirty thousand years before
episode four is because in the Star Wars
mythos there were a lot of things that
were going on outside of the movies I
mean there were a lot of comics that
were being written a lot of books that
were being written that we're really
expanding on a lot of the Star Wars
mythos and so if we said a year before
Episode four in reality it's a year
before the Battle of Yavin because blue
Skywalker took a little bit of time for
him to like find that rebellion and then
join the rebellion and then go off and
face off against the Death Star things
like that so it would create a little
bit of confusion and it would create
some continuity issues and so for the
most part whenever you see BBY just
think of it as you know thirty or
however many years you know before that
particular battle the fight against the
Death Star at the climax of Episode four
and so the reason why I give you that
frame of reference is because this story
picks up around 36,000 years before that
battle in saw Wars Episode four it's a
massive amount of time you know way back
in the past and what we end up doing
here is we actually picking a end up
picking up with a race called the die
bindu and what they're basically doing
is they are worshipping something called
the thoa you're not only that they've
arrived on other planets and we'll talk
about that here in a second but what
this seems to indicate is that while
this throw your has been here for quite
some time that this race as it's been
progressing has basically been
worshipping the throw you're now again
because we're not giving you given any
definitive details it's kind of up to us
to sort of put our finger on it and sort
of say okay how do we interpret this so
what we could probably get away with
here is basically saying this though you
are probably appeared in the very early
days of the dye bindu society when they
were still relatively primitive and so
like any race that comes across
something they don't understand they
will either destroy it or they'll
worship it as a god and that's
essentially kind of what happened here
now as time progressed it really stopped
being this though your is a God so much
as this though your houses secrets that
are waiting to be discovered but the
funny thing about this is something that
I hope you notice is there's reference
to the idea that philosophers and
mystics since the kind of energy being
emitted from this though yours and so
what this does is it lays the seeds for
basically saying that people began to
emerge various alien races began to
emerge with some of their members being
sensitive to the force and so what is up
happening is that somewhere along the
line that though you're activates and
when it does it basically begins
grabbing members who are sensitive to
its tune and essentially meeting they're
sensitive to the force they board the
authorial and they basically take off
for parts unknown and the same thing
happens on other planets across the
entire galaxy the Wookiees on Kashyyyk
for example heal all these different
people all these different races that
basically have philosophers mystics who
are able to feel the force more or less
are brought aboard the thor you're and
there's essentially taken off to the
center of the galaxy now what is up
happening here is they're brought to
this sort of force-sensitive planet
called - and the whole idea behind this
is that - is in a state of flux it's
really one of these things were kind of
a testing ground in the sense that when
these force sensitives are brought to
tyson what they begin to realize is that
the song they're hearing so to speak or
the energy they're picking up is the
force itself and so over the course of
you know several years they began
tapping into the force itself and using
the force for a variety of different
purposes some of it was used to tame
wild beasts others were used to
basically sort of meditate and learn
what it is that they could do with the
force moving objects around different
things like that but as time began to
progress what they began to notice is
that the planet Tyson because it was
very much a force sensitive planet and
it was in a state of flux the only way
to keep the planet calm which is to say
to stop these massive earthquakes
volcanic eruptions different things like
that was to basically be in tune with
the force and so that's the difference
here this is the difference between the
original Jedi and the Jedi as we know
them now Luke Skywalker and like Rey
they basically follow the light side of
the force whereas you have Darth Vader
and like Emperor Palpatine you know and
like kylo Ren who follow the dark side
of the force
initially it wasn't like that a perfect
balance is what had to exist and that's
why there's all these illusions in the
Star Wars mythos bringing balance to the
force because it all hails back to the
original world of the Jedi now of course
even then the way they were pronounced
spelled back in was actually a lot
different than it is now now it was just
je di but back then it was je apostrophe
da III so I mean how you pronounce it I
think it's kind of up to interpretation
I mean I would just call it like Jedi
but it is cool because as the these
various force sensitives began to learn
that the peaceful nature of the planet
was contingent on how in tune they were
with the balance in the force they began
to realize they had to maintain balance
almost 100% of the time following this
they began doing things like erecting
civilizations more or less building a
society for themselves and so again it's
very much the origin of it all how it
all starts now following this the most
logical scenario begins to unfold in the
sense that these various beings start to
procreate and again another difference
between the modern-day Jedi modern-day
Jedi in Star Wars are not allowed to
maintain relationships the idea is that
if they start to engage in love
different things like that then it can
lead them down the path to the dark side
by allowing a motion to invoke feelings
that they would otherwise have to shy
away from and so because of this some of
these children who were born to these
force sensitive people were themselves
not force sensitive and so as a result
what they ended up finding is the planet
itself became very very harsh and
dangerous to those who were not in
balance with the force and so of course
just for the sake of making sure that
these individuals stayed safe as well as
keep the planet in harmony they began
sort of casting off their children now
it wasn't something done out of malice
it was one of those things where a lot
of people began to feel emotions they
were basically cutting off a piece of
themselves they didn't want to you but
it's what was required of them but
notice this they begin to sort of
transition to this idea that the force
is a way of life it's not a concept that
you think about it's not a belief system
it's a way in which you live your life
and in order for them to live their
lives in this fashion they basically
have to move those who are not force
sensitive away from the planet and so
what we end up finding out is that type
in itself was orbited by two suns one of
these was a son called Ashla and the
other one was
Boggan now initially these beings began
to take up residence those who are more
or less pushed out took up residence on
the moons and then of course from there
began expanding out into the rest of the
galaxy as it existed but this is
interesting because a kind of Creed is
form as it's given here the concept of
the Jedi and even the Sith in terms of a
mystic order of monks and philosophers
who form an organized society who are
more like the Shaolin than anything else
is really one of these things where they
sort of form like a Creed for themselves
for those of you guys who are familiar
with regards to modern-day Jedi this
original oath is actually pretty
different
there is no ignorance there is knowledge
there is no fear there is power I am the
heart of the force
I am the revealing fire of life I am the
mystery of the darkness in balance with
chaos and harmony this is the whole idea
of the original Jedi they were in
balance with the force how these things
began unfold is still relatively
primitive at this point in time but the
great thing about a lot of these stories
is they'll go on to do things like you
know the like this is really part of a
story called for storm well there's
things like the force war there's the
first Jedi who fell to the dark side
they became Dark Jedi eventually
discovered the race called the Seth more
or less you know gave themselves the
same name return waged war against the
Jedi you have things like the great
hyperspace war you have all these
scenarios it began to unfold that sort
of brought in this whole early day and
the early formations and then of the
eventual rise of the Sith Empire that
existed in direct opposition to the Jedi
themselves but again all these people
are basically finding balance they
recognize as a dark side of the force
they recognize there's a light side of
the force they recognize both sides have
their use and they strike a balance in
between the two of them it's not by
choice it's by necessity because of what
the planet dictates in terms of how
individuals function now one of the
first major test of the Jedi basically
began to come awry when we ended up
having a particular woman who rose to
prominence on one of the settled worlds
the other half of this is that because
the children of these Jedi were
basically pushed out and sent to other
worlds raised by other individuals or
what-have-you these kids basically
became estranged to their parents and so
when a woman named Hadiya basically
began the process of going through and
conquering all these worlds and
impressing them all under her service
meaning she was a queen of you know
entire systems when she began to look at
the Jedi and refused to accept their
teachings and essentially spark a war
called the decimal war between her own
Empire and the Jedi themselves this
basically
two Jedi who ended up having to fight
their own kids but what this began to do
was sow the seeds of the idea of the
formation of Dark Jedi that subject I
began to come to this belief that with
them losing the kind of things that they
did that maybe balance in the force
isn't necessarily the way to go that
peace in the galaxy has to exist but
sometimes the only way to ensure that
peace is to force people into it now in
truth we're kind of reading between the
lines here we're really just sort of
inferring this based on the information
that we have in truth I would argue the
despot war was probably more in tune
with forming the modern-day Jedi as we
know them in the sense that with this
war being so colossal banning so many
systems and so many planets and
involving so many people that I would
imagine a lot of the Jedi as we know
them now you know these members that
existed back then
basically began to sort of cut
themselves off from emotion different
things like that and simply saying that
there were people who weren't able to
you know quote/unquote pull the trigger
on various enemies or various forces or
so on and so forth and as a result their
weakness comes in the fact that they are
too emotional we're kind of inferring
these things this origin story is pretty
quick I mean it kind of expands a lot
more during the actual force storm story
the events following this desperate war
you know how this Jedi society began to
sort of cope with these different things
what eventually led into the formation
of the Dark Jedi you know a lot of
that's covered in like for storm and
force Wars and things like that but in
terms of how the Jedi came to be how
people were able to tap into the force
for the very first time this is it
remember this is very ambiguous there's
a lot of cloak-and-dagger stuff here you
know for the most part all we know is
that these you know thought you were
just on planets one day the forces
existed for quite some time people began
to rise that were able to tap into the
force the Thor you are grabbed them took
them to the center of the galaxy threw
them on a force-sensitive planet they
had to find balance in order to keep the
planet in check they cast off those who
weren't force sensitive and that was
really about it you know from there they
began to evolve and progress and grow
according to their own creeds and
philosophies and different things like
that but again it's pretty interesting
pretty quick but I think it's pretty fun
you know it's definitely one of the more
interesting origin stories us out there
in terms of the various heroes and
characters that exist in in fiction I
think it's pretty cool but if you guys
are new here to comment explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]